Then in No.
Three, you started SNL,
but you started as a writer
and you're not on air until
oh five, I think.
Yeah, that's correct. Yeah.
No, I'm just trying for fun.
I mean, I get to do
little things in the monologues here
and there
and, you know,
play extras and different sketches,
which was which was flattering.
But yeah,
I mean, full on imposter syndrome.
Heroes of mine had been,
you know, not hired
or let go from that job.
I didn't think it was going to last
very long.
I didn't unpack my boxes.
I lived at 46th Street
so I could get there.
And then, you know,
I was ready to hop on a plane
the second they were like,
Yeah, we messed up.
I mean, I knew it, you know?
Did you
did you think that you were going
to be able to be on the cast
where you bombed that you didn't get?
Oh, yeah, I was bombed.
I mean, there were times
I called my manager,
who's still my manager
now, and I call him ago.
I don't think I'm doing this right.
And and he's just like,
no, you're actually in show biz now,
you know,
not that I don't think, you know,
Second City or,
you know, that is show business.
But I knew what he meant was really just
it wasn't something that I
thought I had a knack for
because I had spent,
you know,
the years prior
really kind of developing,
learning my own voice.
And so here
I was in charge and being paid for it
at a high, breakneck pace
of writing for other people.
But what I loved
more than anything
was the rewrite table like
and getting to like
try on a Fred Armisen,
you know, character,
a Maya Rudolph character,
and then portraying it at the table
and then having someone like Tina,
you know, or Dennis McNicholas, you know.
Yeah. What's that?
What do you say?
Like, we'll use that joke
and then put that in. You can't help it.
That feels like it puts little,
little currency,
you know,
drops a quarter or two
in, you know, the artist jackpot or,
you know,
slot machine and you kind of like, okay,
we'll see.
We'll see what else we got.
And yeah, just kept little by little.
But you know, I was disappointed though
even though it's an incredible job,
it felt a little bit
like winning a gold medal
in the airport
that you don't train as much for.
Oh, you know, you know,
you wanted to be on camera.
You want to be on stage.
You know that because that's what I knew.
But but it didn't feel like from a
prideful place
or but maybe that's stuff
I haven't unlocked yet.
I mean,
there must be something to that, but
I just want to do it, do a good job.
I want to do, you know,
at any point try to reach my
full potential, even if I
even if I'm
crazy and how much I think it is or silly
and how little I think it is.
And oh, and live from New York.
It's Saturday night in my view.
You have done the best,
Joe Biden,
that SNL has a lot of competition, Jake.
It's for art.
It's art for me. For me, it's hard.
That's more of a dickhead thing to say
than anything. Sketch comedy is an art.
All right.
Well, I think I appreciate that.
But it was also a different era of Biden,
as you acknowledge,
when you did that skit not long ago.
Is it weird
meeting people that you've made fun of?
See, I never thought I was making
fun of them.
I've never
I don't think I've played anyone
that I made fun of.
But with all due respect,
this is a bunch of malarkey.
I don't think I can.
You're channeling him,
but I'm playing my dad with, like,
fake teeth.
And, you know,
they give me
they give me nice, big chompers.
I got these, you know, little tiny teeth,
you know.
But I'm always
playing a version of myself again.
I'm not trying to fool anybody.
I'm I try and do prank phone calls
and get people in trouble.
You know, like,
I met him and he was great.
He's gracious, you know?
And you know, as advertised,
you know what I mean?
It's a gift to get to work somewhere,
like starting to live.
It's it's a form of superpower
to be able to impersonate
or or empathize, you know,
physically and vocally,
you know, into someone
however you want to put it,
channel someone, if you will.
I'd prefer
to use it
to celebrate
what I like about them versus
the other words.
I've been asked to do things
I remember on
us, and I can't think of any brief time
I had that
I just didn't have a connection to
and I didn't want to.
It feels it feels mean
if it felt mean spirited.
And I've already been, you know,
born into a vessel
that's afforded
a great deal of privilege.
And I didn't want to like,
you know, use that in a negative way.
It's not a pejorative imitation,
you know, it's
the Camaro waxing gas machine.
Yeah. Joe Biden of, like, 15 years ago.
Yeah, yeah.
Not the guy we got now.
I mean, from eight years ago, man.
The ghost of Biden past beau.
Yeah. When you leave the boss, you can't.
That's
that's tough as the
repercussions on a global scale
if not the Nasdaq you know
so like Joe Biden you look different.
I mean the other people have played
it sends me
I think it's been like Mulaney,
Woody Harrelson and Jim Carrey,
like all like
great guys
and all like incredible artists
within their own
sort of like lose the gig or whatever,
you know, is like, no, no, no.
It's like that's, that's yeah,
it was,
never mind to begin
with, you know, like,
I only got it because I happen to be.
But I remember Fred Armisen
calling me in 2008
when Obama had selected President
Biden as his running mate
and Fred calling me, go, hey, congrats.
I was like, why? What happened?
Because Biden got picked.
Joe Biden and Chris Dodd.
I go,
So what do you play them
in that Halloween sketch?
Remember when Obama came?
I was like, Oh, yeah,
oh, that's fun.
And it was like, so it wasn't like you.
It just sort of
wasn't like Tina to Sarah Palin.
It wasn't like this automatic.
We have to do this.
No, no, you'd already been.
I had already done that.
They'd already fitted me for the wig.
Not bad.
It not a bad thing to fall into and
and then.
Yeah,
then they get to play against Tina
as Sarah Palin in, in the 2008
election sketches.
Joe, of course.
Okay, because I practiced
a couple of zingers
where I call you Jill. Okay, great.
And then I just got to like,
you know, ducking, you know, bob
and weave throughout and all that.
But it's been fun to play
elements of him.
I mean, you know,
be able to play Joe
Biden and Mitt Romney
and like in the same political season,
darn it all, to heck,
you know, that's range.